krebs mit smartphone diagnostizieren mit
einem gadget ist das nicht ein bisschen
unsicher und vielleicht gefährlich mehr
dazu jetzt wirklich von 2006 mit einem
quad von inklusive gadget kann man ja
schon lange so einiges analysieren
angefangen bei den menschlichen
vitalwerte bis hin zu krebs diagnose
krebs diagnose tatsächlich forscher der
universität haben ein gadget entwickelt
dass es in zukunft möglich machen soll
krebsgeschwüre bakterien und viren zu
diagnostizieren die wissenschaftler im
fachmagazin nature communications
berichten würde dafür ein einziges
instrument auf einem 3d drucker mit led
dioden ausreichen und tatsächlich kaum
zu glauben aber man konnte mit dem 3 d
drucker gadget dna-sequenzen analysieren
klingt super schräg aber auf der anderen
seite auch wirklich viel sprechen
auf der homepage der bub sala
universität heiße status pete today dna
sequenzen ist annette laboratories of
large rostete small freddie prinze
microscope can make the technology
available to more people even in pure
partner of the world im mikroskop zu
mass effect on the edge of glory of
honor dort einen ort die penal on
wednesday playoffs elektrizität sind
langlauf mit phones batterie zitat ende
ganz klar wird das gadget den durchbruch
schaffen könnte das in krisengebieten
viel bewirken und bleibt ja in den
händen von fachkräften also
vielversprechend und sinnvolle
medizinische geräte aus dem 3d drucker
sind schließlich auch nichts neues mehr
inzwischen ist es ja sogar möglich
unterschiedliche organe aus den
unterschiedlichsten geweben zu drucken
und griff bildet dabei das kollagen ein
molekül das als wichtiger bestandteil
dem körper bei knochen sehnen muskeln
bändern und haut ist bei allen
körperteilen wie belastbar sein müssen
es hat dabei eigenschaften wie
kohlefaser und kann
bezogen auf die erdanziehungskraft das
10.000 fache des eigengewichtes als
zugkraft halten
auf diese weise werden die
grundstrukturen für organe und jedwede
körperteile gefertigt sogar
funktionierende muskeln können daraus
gezüchtet werden wie sie die entwicklung
des 3d jedoch vor allem im medizinischen
bereich oder töne geräusche erfindungen
zu weit gehend ich freue mich auf eure
meinung und die diskussion unter diesem
video und natürlich auch über den hier
einen daumen nach oben und natürlich ein
kostenloses abo dafür einfach hier
klicken und dann verpackt er kein video
und ansonsten bis dann